bonjour à toutes et à tous nous
souhaitons bon de commencer rendre
hommage à une grande marche députés les
républicains depuis 2008 qui était maire
de thionville depuis 2014 une femme
engagée une femme de conviction qui a
mis notamment toutes les problématiques
économiques au coeur de son action
service de son territoire et qui depuis
plusieurs années mené un combat dur très
dur contre la maladie qui a fini par
l'emporter
nous retiendrons d'elle son sourire nous
reviendrons à elle ses convictions sont
en vie et nos pensées notre affection à
son conjoint
merci valérie nous sommes donc
aujourd'hui réunit aussi avec philippe
genin pour ce point presse hebdomadaire
et si vous le permettez j'aimerais
commencer par vous donner l'agenda suite
à plusieurs déplacements notre président
vous le savez s'était rendu dans le nord
dans le loiret dans l'orne et bien la
semaine prochaine il fera un déplacement
dans 3 pour prendre part dont il fera un
déplacement de trois jours dans le sud
de la france puis concernant les
conventions nous aurons une convention
le mardi 3 mai convention sur
l'environnement et l'énergie
valérie va vous faire maintenant un
point d'actualité sur les élections
partielles
merci brigitte effectivement de
résultats qui retiennent notre attention
à l'issue de ce week end
en ce qui concerne la législative
partielle partiale pardon de la 3e
circonscription de loire atlantique qui
voit arriver en tête le candidat du
parti socialiste nous voyons néanmoins
un effondrement spectaculaire avec 25
points de perdus sur cette
circonscription par rapport à l'élection
de monsieur ayrault qui était passé au
premier tour avec 56 % et une forte
progression qui est enregistrée pour le
candidat des républicains donc dans une
circonscription qui de façon évidente
n'est absolument pas aisée pour notre
formation politique nous félicitons et
nous encourageons évidemment l'ensemble
des électeurs à porter
leur envoi au deuxième tour pour le seul
candidat qui peut amener un vrai
changement dans le cadre d'une
alternance à cette circonscription et
ses habitants c'est à dire monsieur anoh
nous souhaitons évoqué également une
cantonale partielle qui s'est déroulé à
saint mihiel dans la meuse c'était lors
des dernières élections au départemental
le seul canton qui avait basculé dans
cette région au front national
suite à un recours il y a eu une
partielle et nous sommes très heureux de
voir que contrairement à la dernière
fois c'est les candidats udi soutenues
par les républicains qui l'ont emporté
avec un gain de 3 points par rapport aux
précédentes élections ils sont dans
situations extrêmement positif pour
l'emporter et nous serons ravis si cela
peut se faire que l'ensemble des
personnes qui ne souhaitent ne plus
avoir aucun département qui soit dans
cette partie de notre pays emportés par
le front national
ils puissent y concourir et nous les
encourageons évidemment extrêmement
vivement oui un petit pois d'actualité
et revenir sur cette semaine politique à
nouveau chargé chargé particulièrement à
gauche avec évidemment cette émission de
télévision dialogue citoyen qui pour
nous est égal à dialogue pour rien en
effet un président de la république qui
vient devant les français tout en étant
sourd à leurs attentes à leur angoisse
pour ne rien dire c'est pire que tout si
ce n'est dire que tout va bien quand
depuis le début du septennat au
quinquennat nous le savons tous c'est
sept cent mille chômeurs en plus que
nous devons à monsieur hollande françois
hollande qui avec 14 % seulement
d'opinions favorables a donc le record
de la popularité des présidents de la
république
non seulement aucun président de la
république n'avait eu ce score et ce
score qui maintenant est en train de
s'installer dans la durée
c'est donc un pays qui pour lui aller
mieux qui nous a décrit quand vous le
savez je le rappelais à l'instant c'est
un pays qui va de plus en plus mal et
qui est pour l'instant otage de
l'ambition de françois hollande
en effet la popularité qui
devrait l'inciter à réformer or c'est
tout l'un vers ce qui se passe puisque
nous sommes vous l'avez bien compris
dans un immobilisme qui est en train de
s'installer et que je crois
malheureusement va perdurer
l'immobilisme restant la règle
apparemment pour monsieur hollande
je voudrais vous rappeler juste quelques
phrases qu'avait dit nicolas sarkozy
entre les deux tours des élections
présidentielles pour vous rappeler que
ce qui nous arrive et est pratiquement
écrit d'avancé
en tout cas c'est est ce que nous
précisait à l'époque nicolas sarkozy
il disait que la république de
l'impuissance c'est celle qui ne décide
de rien il rappelait ce que pourrait
être une france gouvernée par la gauche
une france qui se retrouveraient
affaibli politiquement économiquement et
moralement cette gauche qui fait la
morale aux autres mais ne se
l'appliquent jamais elle même cette
gauche qui détestent l'argent sauf quand
c'est le sien
cette gauche qui condamne la réussite
sauf danse est la sienne cette gauche
qui ne passe rien aux hôtes et qui se
permet tout cette gauche qui se permet
de trier entre les bons et les mauvais
français
ceux qui pense comme elle et les mauvais
français ceux qui ne pensent pas comme
elle
quand ils ont fini de distribuer ce
qu'ils n'ont pas quand la faillite se
profile quand la confiance s'effondre il
se rallie en catastrophe à l'austérité
eh bien c'est ce en effet à quoi
aujourd'hui nous assistons car le
président hollande si je disais qu'il
avait 14 % d'opinions favorables dans le
dernier sondage aujourd'hui sorti dans
le figaro c'est seulement 11% maintenant
d'intentions de vote qui souhaite donc
qu'il soit à nouveau candidat pour 2017
c'est donc de président affaibli
françois hollande passe à président en
voie de disparition
avec une telle la popularité est une
autorité bafouée
il ne dispose maintenant plus d'aucune
marge de manoeuvre président sortant il
est donc que sondés entre 13 et 16 %
d'intentions de vote c'est à dire
pratiquement le score que fait
maintenant l'extrême gauche
du jamais vu c'est donc cette
déliquescence du pouvoir
à laquelle nous insistons qui est pour
nous historique et qui nous inquiète
particulièrement
certains même dans son propre camp l'ont
déjà mis de côté je voudrais vous
rappeler ce que anne hidalgo a rappelé
cette semaine pour qui sauf miracle il y
aura alternance en 2017
c'est donc dans ce climat délétère que
le ps a essayé de trouver une bonne idée
cette idée sortie du chapeau en créant
la belle alliance populaire tentative
apparemment désespérée d'un ps qui ne
sait plus où il habite pour vouloir
échappé à la noyade mais qui a fait
pschitt puisque vous le savez dans cette
belle alliance populaire souhaité par le
ps ni les verts ni les communistes n'ont
en fait partie je voudrais d'ailleurs
rappelé que dans les élections
législatives dont valérie de bord vient
de rappeler le résultat du premier tour
le candidat vert arrivé en troisième
position n'a d'ailleurs pas donné de
consigne de vote ce qui vous montre
l'ambiance de cette gauche plurielle
enfin monsieur macro qui a fait beaucoup
parler de lui dans les magazines people
a eu qui fait plusieurs déclarations
cette semaine les déclarations parfois
dont le calendrier était pour le moins
concomitant avec l'action
gouvernementale ce qui n'a pas
évidemment facilité les choses mais il a
eu une phrase et je voudrais donc vous
proposer qui m'a particulièrement
interpellé sur la bbc et je voudrais
donc vous proposer que l'on décerne le
prix de l'humour politique à emmanuel
macron pour sa phrase à la bbc je pense
que si françois hollande prend des
décisions très courageuses et s'il
explique ce qu'il fait il pourrait être
certainement en situation de gagner
voilà qui méritait d'être rappelé
mais on l'a compris je le rappelais tout
à l'heure françois hollande est
complètement sourd aux critiques il est
aveugle à la situation et malgré tout il
croit encore
l'opération dont sauvons le candidat
hollande a commencé en effet à quoi
assistons-nous et bien là c'est en ce
dernier jour c'est entre 8 et 10
milliards de promesses non financées qui
on était
c c'est donc un président en campagne un
président en campagne dont valérie de
bord va vous parler
merci merci brigitte effectivement un
président épuisé mais qui épuise les
finances de la france puisque il vient
de tirer 8 à 10 milliards d'euros de
chèque en blanc sur le dos de nos
concitoyens 8 à 10 milliards d'euros
on a eu la garantie jeunes on a eu les
500000 formation pour les jeunes qui ne
sont évidemment toujours pas financé et
puis nous venons d'avoir un rapport
parlementaire avec un rmi jeune 250
euros par mois qui pourrait toucher
évidemment un certain nombre de
personnes donc on voit que tous ces
chèques en blanc donné de façon
clientéliste et électoralistes vont
assécher encore un peu plus des recettes
et des finances publiques qui sont dans
un état moribond et il nous semble
important de poser aujourd'hui les
jalons par rapport à ce président en
campagne
les comptes de campagne c'est un an
avant
comme monsieur hollande a manifestement
l'intention d'être en campagne nous
souhaitons attirer l'attention de toutes
et tous sur ses comptes et sur la façon
dont ils utilisent aujourd'hui ses
déplacements nous avons noté qu'il a
fait un déplacement récemment au liban
qu'il a rencontré la communauté
française comme il le fait à chaque fois
mais que cette rencontre s'apparente
bien davantage à un meeting politique de
candidats futurs car la rencontre du
président de la république française
avec ses concitoyens qui sont installés
à l'étranger
donc nous souhaitons désormais qu'il y
ait une séparation stricte entre les
déplacements du président et les
déplacements du candidat deuxième
élément sur lequel nous souhaitons
attirer l'attention
dans le même registre de ce candidat en
campagne c'est un certain nombre de
nominations qui ne lasse pas d'attirer
notre attention voir nos interrogations
nous avons eu françois chérèque qui a
été nommé haut commissaire à
l'engagement au service fondu
certainement nous avons un certain
nombre de bruit qui sont arrivés jusqu'à
nous sur le départ du patron d'air
france or nous savons que suite au
lynchage du drh nous avons déjà la
conseillère sociale de monsieur valls
qui est arrivé pour remplacer le
rh d'air france il semblerait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la directrice de
cabinet de monsieur valls qui serait en
pôle position pour remplacer le patron
d'air france comment cela va-t-il se
passer dans quelles conditions dans
quelle transparence des nominations
souvenez-vous de la tirah goy président
je ferai en sorte que les nominations de
hauts fonctionnaires se fasse dans la
transparence la transparence elle est
quand même pour le moins extrêmement
éloignée en la matière et dernier point
mais certainement le plus important et
sur celui sur lequel nous nous
interrogeons le plus nous apprenons que
pour faire en sorte que monsieur le pan
éphémère patron de la cgt puisse assurer
s'assurer un fauteuil et rebondir
il y aurait la création d'une agence de
lutte contre l'illettrisme avec une
création de poste de directeur
rémunérées non seulement cette page en
salles existent déjà il y à une agence
qui lutte contre l'illettrisme dont la
présidente et bénévoles qui travaillent
extrêmement bien avec des rapports
d'activité extrêmement positif mais
enfin ce n'est pas grave on veut doubler
un dispositif existant mais d'autres
méthodes socialiste bien connu mais tout
ça pour faire plaisir à la cgt ou pas
nous interrogeons le congrès de la cgt
est en train de se nouer
est ce que le gouvernement est en train
de tenter d'apaiser les relations
sociales avec la cgt dans un contexte et
un climat social et politique difficile
avec la loi travail
c'est une question qui mérite de notre
point de vue clarification temps de la
cgt que du gouvernement je passe la
parole à un poids pour revenir sur le
phénomène nuit debout avant que philippe
chemin notre porte parole monde un point
comme d'habitude europe et affaires
internationales un petit point en effet
sur sur nuit debout
nuit debout et il y à la version la
perception qu'en ont les français il ya
la perception qu'en ont les élus je
voudrais vous donner ma perception en
tout cas des luttes paris en tant que
maire d'arrondissement
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire mais je
vais aujourd'hui le redire ce qui se
passe à paris est tout simplement
inadmissible c'est inadmissible qu'on
arrive à un tel point des
responsabilités au niveau gouvernemental
qu'on laisse perdurer une telle
situation on a bien compris que les
origines du mouvement dont d'abord on
nous avait fait croire ils étaient
spontanées quand il était
particulièrement organisé ça n'est pas
là le problème on pouvait avoir un
regard peut-être pour le moins attentif
un petit woodstock et tente est en train
de s'installer en se disant c'est bien
la parole et libéré la parole elle est
libérée mais ça n'est pas que la parole
qui s'est libérée c'est la violence qui
s'est libérée alors ce qui était
possible peut-être un soir de soir et
qui maintenant perdure perdure dans des
conditions qui ne sont pas acceptables
qui ne sont pas acceptables pour les
riverains qui ne sont pas acceptables
pour les commerçants qui ne sont pas
acceptables pour les parisiens dans leur
ensemble car nous sommes à l'heure
actuelle dans un état d'urgence je tiens
à leur rappeler
nous avons des difficultés à faire
surveiller nos écoles nos crèches en ce
moment car avec le plan vigipirate les
attentes sont nombreuses des familles or
que voit-on la police mobilisée en ce
moment pour contrôler des manifestants
qui n'ont qu'une envie en découlant en
découdre avec eux en découdre avec la
société
cette société dont il rêve qu'elle
devienne meilleur cette société donc
quand on souhaite un monde meilleur et
bien on fait en sorte cela se fasse dans
le respect de l'autre le respect de
l'autre qui est bafouée nous l'avons vu
avec ce qui s'est passé ce week-end avec
une place de la république qui chaque
jour et laissé dans un état de soudure
inadmissible où la devise de la mairie
de paris de la ville de paris floch twh
nets mergitur a été tagué ou des injures
sont prononcées aux policiers où on nous
voyons encore une fois des dégradations
je le redis
cette situation ne peut pas durer nous
demandons à nouveau au président de la
république à ce gouvernement de prendre
ses responsabilités et ne peut pas y
avoir deux poids deux mesures comment
pouvoir faire acte d'autorité quand on
n'est pas capable de faire respecter sur
une place de la capitale
un minimum j'allais dire de calme et
surtout quand on voit ce qui s'est passé
dernièrement donc nuit debout pour nous
les indignés de hollande doivent stopper
et nous demandons au ministre de
l'intérieur de procéder maintenant à la
suspension de l'autorisation
d'occupation de cette place car cette
place monopolise beaucoup trop d'énergie
que ce soit les forces de l'ordre que ce
soit les services de la propreté chaque
matin que ce soit aussi par rapport à
tous ceux qui habitent autour et dois je
vous le rappeler cette place de la
république qui était l'emblème du
recueillement par rapport à tous les
événements tragiques que nous avons
connue donc particulièrement évidemment
les attentats de novembre
nous ne pouvons accepter de cette
situation perdure merci pour terminer là
effectivement il complétait sur mis
debout
objectivement on est dans un monde qui
se veut démocratique mais qui ne l'est
pas du tout on a vu ce qui s'est passé
avec finkielkraut ce week-end qui est
totalement inacceptable
donc ce n'est pas de la démocratie c'est
c'est de la singerie de démocratie ce ne
serait pas de la discussion sont des
palabres à n'en plus finir et au fond on
a face à nous des gens qui sont soit des
étudiants trentenaires ou des indignés
professionnels qui en réalité ne sont
pas du tout révolutionnaire mais
profondément conservateur
ultraconservateur ultra protectionnistes
extrêmement égoïstes ils ne veulent rien
changer un système et on l'a bien vu
ils ont réussi à bloquer la fameuse
wye.n comrie qui avait en son sein
quelques à quelques quelques avancées
qu'ils pouvaient débloquer le marché du
travail mais ces gens là ne veulent pas
que les choses changent parce que ils
bénéficient d'un système dont ils sont
donc ils sont les quarts en sur les
questions européennes puisque j'ai
plaisir la joie de d'aborder les goûts
ses sujets avec mémé de mes deux
collègues d'abord simplement une
observation extrêmement simple c'est
quand le président de la république a
pris la parole la semaine dernière la
question européenne a été totalement
absente alors qu'au fond toutes les
questions d'immigration
toutes les questions de défense la
question de l'ukraine toutes les
questions d'emploi
toutes les questions de défense notre
notre outil industriel sont des
questions européennes
on ne peut pas imaginer que la france
avec ses 65 millions d'habitants
puissent faire face à des géants comme
les états unis la chine l'inde la russie
seul et donc nous avons besoin d'un
échelon de souveraineté un véhicule de
puissance qui est celui qui est celui de
l'europe
et quand on voit qu'aujourd'hui je vais
en parler à des questions fondamentales
sur les équilibres économiques que nous
avons avec la chine pour défendre nos
emplois en france et que le président de
la république durant cette soirée
n'évoque pas du tout la question
européenne mais en reste à une approche
micro de sujets qui le croient qu'ils
croient contrôlé au plan politiciens en
réalité c'est absolument ahurissant
je pense que tous les prédécesseurs de
françois hollande de gauche ou de droite
qui ont tous mené des politiques
européennes doivent absolument se
demander où est passée la france
le parti socialiste longtemps a été
européen il ne l'est clairement plus
alors quelles sont les nouvelles du
front européen
nous avons été en session parlementaire
la semaine dernière à strasbourg
donc plusieurs textes ont été votés je
pourrai répondre aux questions que vous
le souhaitez sur les textes que vous
souhaitez bien entendu je voulais
aborder de trois sujets le premier point
c'est le fameux pnr le fameux feuilleton
sur le passenger name record d'heures
qui a été enfin voter rappelons que
c'est un sujet qui est très important
pour la sécurité des français même s'il
n'est évidemment pas l'alpha et l'oméga
de des outils de lutte contre le
terrorisme il est utile et indispensable
il n'est pas suffisant mais il est
indispensable et nous les républicains
depuis le début de ce texte nous avons
toujours soutenu
l'approbation d'un tel texte au
parlement européen nous avons été
constants ce qui n'a pas été le cas des
socialistes qui ont toujours lutté
contre ce texte et il a fallu les
attentats malheureux de paris et surtout
de bruxelles pour que les choses se
débloquent
toutefois je note qu'il y a eu des votes
de france est négatif à strasbourg
contre le pnr monsieur mélenchon madame
joly
les députés du front national ont voté
contre le pnr alors même que la question
de la protection des données
individuelles qui était un élément qui
était encore en débat avait été résolu
donc l'attentisme et la grande
ambiguïtés des socialistes d'un côté et
la constance dans la négation du sujet
par d'autres acteurs les communistes et
l'extrême droite on retrouve toujours
bien entendu cette y compris en matière
économique mais là aussi on retrouve
cette alliance de fait et bien est
absolument là aussi extrêmement
surprenante ne reste pas moins que vous
allez pouvoir vous intéresser encore
dans les semaines et les mois à venir au
pnr parce que ce qui a été voté au
parlement c'est une disposition
législative directives qu'il faut
maintenant transposer en droit national
et dans la vie active il est dit que les
états ont deux ans pour le transposer et
nous aux républicains nous appelons le
gouvernement français a transposé sans
délai cette directive c'est la terre ne
pas attendre un ou deux ans de mise
de transposition les républicains
souhaitent officiellement que le pnr
soit transposée en droit national dans
les plus brefs délais nous pouvons le
faire maintenant il s'agit d'une
question de simple de volonté politique
évidemment on peut imaginer que le
gouvernement français qui tient le
discours nous voulons le pnr face à des
députés socialistes qui disent nous n'en
voulons pas le gouvernement va peut-être
là aussi joué la carte du n'importe quoi
en de l'attentisme et notre crainte
c'est que les français la france
gouvernement français en terre le pnr
européen 6 il joue sur la vitesse de la
transposition deuxième point qui est un
point sur laquelle on va revenir durant
cette année c'est la question de la
place de la chine dans l'économie
mondiale de trois explications au mois
de décembre prochain
la décision va devoir être prises par
les grandes puissances mondiales de
savoir si on accorde à la chine le
statut d'économie de marché
la décision devra être prise fin
novembre ou début décembre j'ai pu
l'atteindre en tête mais il ya une date
limite et c'est un sujet qui nous
préoccupe considérablement puisque nous
considérons nous que la chine n'a pas du
tout les qualités pour entrer dans le
groupe d économie de marché
économie dirigée politique sociale
médiocre travail des enfants conditions
environnementales
enfin le droit du travail la chine n'est
pas le paradis des travailleurs ils s'en
foutent beaucoup et tout ça fait que
nous ne souhaitons pas que la chine
devienne statut d'économie de marché
notre crainte c'est que une tête des
ciseaux ne doit pas être discutée dix
jours avant la date limite
notre crainte c'est que le gouvernement
français ne s'intéressent pas à la
question parce que il a la tête ailleurs
et que ça serait une décision lourde à
prendre politiquement et donc il a eu
cette semaine une décision prise par la
commission européenne qui a attiré notre
attention et qui allume une petite
lumière clignotante c'est que vous avez
entendu parler du fonds européen pour
les investissements stratégiques c'est
le fameux plan juncker donc je vous
parle je rappelle le point en choeur ses
315 milliards d'euros a mené par des
entreprises avec une contribution des
états membres de 42 milliards d'euros et
de la banque européenne d'investissement
21 milliards d'euros et donc
l'adjonction de ces trois somme va
nourrir un fonds qui va permettre de
faire des investissements en europe et
bien la chine est la première état
étranger à participer à ce fonds et la
chine a annoncé la semaine dernière
qu'ils allaient mettre 10 milliards
d'euros sur la table
donc d'un côté nous nous félicitons de
ces 10 milliards d'euros qui vont
contribuer à la croissance européenne
s'il ya quelques uns des milliards qui
veulent venir en france nous serions
très contents de les accueillir mais en
même temps il ne faut pas que ça soit un
blanc seing à la chine pour qu'elle
puisse se voir octroyer le statut
d'économie de marché autrement dit c'est
toute la question avec la chine c'est
que c'est un partenaire mais nous
voulons pas être otage de ce partenaire
ait eu l'exemple de la turquie
la cat semaine ou un partenaire nous a
pris en otage ne voulons pas dans un
objet bien plus conséquent quel
équilibre économique mondiale ne
serait-ce que ça la désindustrialisation
de la france ne serait ce que ça nous ne
voulons pas que la france soit prise en
otage et nous appelons le président de
la république à dire clairement sa
position sur la chine économie de marché
il est absolument ahurissant de voir que
le gouvernement français n'a jamais pris
de position claire et définitive sur ce
sujet c'est dans quelques semaines
quelques mois
et donc il faudra prendre une décision
et il faudra annoncer la couleur
troisième point le président de la
république et au liban enfin la bible en
egypte un mot sur le liban l'excellent
or l'orient-le jour qui votre confrère
francophile et francophone libanais
publié à beyrouth
l'orient-le jour a publié ce matin
peut-être est assis hier un éditorial et
j'ai pêché dans cet éditorial une phrase
qui résume la le sentiment des libanais
lors de la visite du président hollande
au liban la phrase est la suivante gelé
notées pour ne pas trahir le verbe de
votre confrère à quoi a réellement servi
cette visite présidentielle
à quoi a réellement servi cette visite
présidentielle voilà ce que dit la
presse libanaise au sortir des 24 ou 48
heures de françois hollande au liban
pourquoi à parce qu'en fait françois
hollande a fait comme
son interview télévisée il est arrivé de
bonnes paroles ne leur a pas dit tout va
bien il n'a quand même pas osé il a osé
avec nous il n'a pas osé avec eux mais
en pratique les gens se demandent ce
qu'ils vont faire et je pense qu'il est
venu le faire comme vous l'avez dit en
grande partie une campagne électorale
puisqu'il ya un vote important il ya
beaucoup de français qui réside au liban
de binationaux et s'éteint c'est une
c'est un voyage de compagnie avec un
très grand regret de notre part qui est
la question fondamentale de l'armée
libanaise
l'armée libanaise est une armée qui est
sous-équipée et qui pourtant l armée
d'un pays ami à la france et qui
pourtant est l'armée d'un pays ami de la
france qui à faire face à des chevaux
savez qu'il ya plusieurs fois des
soldats libanais qui ont été enlevés par
des ch et eu des combats entre l'armée
libanaise et des ge est donc ce sont aux
premières loges de la lutte contre l'
état islamique
et pourtant l'armée libanaise manque de
tout quand une quinzaine de leurs
soldats ont été enlevés il ya maintenant
un an et demi c'est parce qu'il n'avait
plus de munitions on en était ce niveau
là on parle pas de rafale du
porte-avions on parle de d'outils de
combat de base est donc un accord avait
été trouvé
la france fournissent à des armes à
l'armée libanaise ces armes étaient
payés à hauteur de 3 milliards d'euros
par l'arabie saoudite
il se trouve que l'arabie saoudite a
décidé de couper les vivres
il ya quelques semaines et donc il ya 2
2 milliards qui sont tant qu'ils sont
bloqués qui sont gelés et la france donc
nous livrent plus d'armes à l'armée
libanaise nous souhaitons que de nouveau
clairement parce que l'armée libanaise
c'est un rempart quand l'autre l'état
islamique nous souhaitons que la france
vivre des armes et aident l'armée
libanaise a résisté à l'état islamique
on ne peut pas d'un côté dire on et vos
amis ce que le président est allé dire
aux libanais mais en même temps
débrouillez-vous sans rien soyez nu face
à l'état islamique et donc nous avons
une responsabilité absolument
fondamental autre exemple d'un double
langage
françois hollande a expliqué par avec de
bonnes paroles qu'il soutenait les
chrétiens d'orient
nous sommes ravis de cette déclaration
le problème c'est que quand on regarde
le nombre de visas accordés l'année
dernière
et cette année en année pleine au
chrétien d'irak
on s'aperçoit que il ya une diminution
de 75 % du nombre de visas donné à m -
l'année dernière aux chrétiens d'irak
versus cette année donc d'un côté on
peut pas dire on aide les chrétiens
d'orient mais en pratique on observe
peut-être y at-il d'autres causes mais
on observe brutalement une diminution
considérable du nombre de visas octroyés
ou chrétiens d'irak
ce qui est évidemment tout à fait
scandaleux 3 4e point sur la turquie
nous avons eu le vote sur la turquie la
semaine dernière avec une résolution le
parlement européen que nous avons
combattu aux républicains et qui
malheureusement a été adopté mais nous
avons voté contre je vous rappelle que
dans cette résolution
incroyable non seulement on acceptait
l'idée de rouvrir d'ouvrir des chapitres
de négociation on acceptait de dire que
le turc pourrait devenir à court terme
une langue officielle de l'union
l'habillage qui à chypre les chiffres
parlent essentiellement grecs turcs et
dernier point
encore plus incroyable c'est qu'il est
accepté que le ministre des affaires
étrangères turc participent aux réunions
du conseil des ministres les affaires
étrangères ce qui est évidemment
absolument incroyable et bien tout ça a
été accepté par les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement dont françois hollande
il ya un mois a été validé par le
parlement européen dans une résolution
la semaine dernière nous avons voté
contre à deviner qu'on fait les membres
du parti socialiste membre du parlement
européen ils ont voté pour ils ont voté
pour cette résolution qui ouvre d ouvre
officiellement des chapitres nouveau
d'adhésion on voit vraiment qu'il ya une
faye très importante entre les
républicains d'un côté les socialistes
de l'autre le discours est extrêmement
ambiguë de la part des socialistes est
en pratique ils supportent ils z
ils soutiennent une telle ou tel texte
enfin dernier point très rapide sur le
sec questions européennes manuel valls
est venue au parlement européen mardi il
y a passé une journée extrêmement
houleuse car nous passons sur le fait
que la courtoisie républicaine et
l'importance pour les députés français
de rencontrer régulièrement quelle que
soit leur couleur politique le
gouvernement en place pour se mettre
d'accord sur comment on défend les
intérêts de la france a été pas fou et
puisque le premier ministre n'est même
pas venu ne serait-ce que avoir un quart
d'heure de discussion avec les députés
qui n'était pas socialiste
habituellement quand un ministre des
affaires européennes qu'ils soient
socialistes pour républicains ont peu
importe bien à strasbourg
il rencontre les députés français pour
faire le point la nouvelle valls n'a pas
nous a pas facile tant pis on
travaillera sans lui il se trouve qu'il
a passé une journée terrible avec ses
amis uniquement socialiste où il s'est
fait extrêmement critiqué par tout le
monde
parce que quoi à des amis européens de
manuel valls ne comprennent pas pourquoi
la france disparaît bref les socialistes
européens ont dit à manuel valls que
nous disons nous de manuel valls c'est
que la france n'existe pas dans le
concert des nations européennes et
qu'elle est totalement absente et ça a
été extrêmement dit et redit par le
groupe socialiste par le président
martin schulz qui présente du parlement
qui est socialiste
le par les socialistes françaises
sortent de thil même s'il ya une sorte
de secret défense sur la teneur de leur
petit déjeuner est manifestement tout ça
a été dit et redit aux premiers 10
j'espère qu'il a compris la france ne
peut pas continuer à être absente des
décisions européennes
et quand elle est absente c'est ce qui
se passe eh bien elle se fait imposer
des lois et des dispositions dont elle
ne veut pas l'exemple caricatural c'est
celui sur la traque j'en ai terminé sur
la cession de la semaine dernière mais
si vous lui posez des questions sur
d'autres textes ça sera avec plaisir